de plus en plus des étudiants de la
guadeloupe et de martinique s'intéresse
à venir étudier au québec
l'uqam reste un de leurs premiers choix
on observe une belle augmentation du
nombre d'étudiants des deux des deux
territoires
on peut dire que la guadeloupe se
démarque de façon assez forte depuis ces
deux trois dernières années avec à peu
près un contingent de 120 d'étudiants
comparativement à la martinique qui a à
peu près 60 prêts étudiants alors c'est
une belle percée du marché depuis notre
présence sur place les secteurs
privilégiés c'est certain que la gestion
reste un atout certain
mais je voudrais également qu'on
retrouve beaucoup de secteurs non
usuelle comme certains secteurs
artistiques en arts visuels et
médiatiques et beaucoup d'intérêt de la
part des étudiants en design graphique
mais également en biologie en
kinésiologie et est probablement un
secteur qui montrent de plus en plus ce
sont les programmes en relations
internationales et droit international
qui sont des programmes de grands
attraits à l'université du québec à
montréal
alors comment se fait l'intégration des
étudiants de guadeloupe et de martinique
ici on est très attiré par le succès de
nos étudiants alors on fait tout pour
qu'ils puissent profiter de leur
présence sur place pour améliorer leurs
bagages personnels l'enrichir alors
l'intégration est faite par un service à
la vie étudiante qui leur offrent des
ateliers d'accueil on également en lien
avec un suivi personnalisé des étudiants
qu'on rencontre à l'étranger en
guadeloupe et en martinique
nous faisons des suivi téléphonique nous
les rencontrons quand il arrive
nous nous assurons également de la
qualité de la formation qu'ils suivent
de l'état de réussite scolaire durant
leur parcours et ils sont soutenus par
un ensemble de professionnels pour
s'assurer que leur séjour d'études se
passe dans les meilleures conditions
possibles et dans la satisfaction de
l'ensemble des étudiants que nous
recevons